The one piece manga finally gave us a glimpse
at the absolutely unbelievable powers of the
mysterious ruler of the world government,
finally ending all speculation whether Imu
and the Gorosei can fight.
They absolutely can.
Plus we learn A TON of absolutely mind-blowing
information about Imu’s true past and confirmation
of their connections with the mysterious Lili
who was introduced in the last chapter.
But what’s even more game changing is that
not one but two individuals saw the secret
ruler and then barely managed to escape.
Which means that very soon we could see the
world government’s darkest secret revealed
to the entire world.
And on top of all that it was confirmed that
Vivi’s family are actually a part of the
legendary D clan, which means that we could
finally learn the secrets about the famous
initial once Vivi reunites with Luffy on Egghead
Island.
And all of this could lead Vivi on a path
of revenge for her father’s death, but overthrowing
the world government and its rulers looks
like it just became way way more difficult.
Because this is the very first time we have
ever seen any of the rulers of the world government
use their powers.
And you cannot even imagine how unbelievably
incredible their abilities are.
Now, what are these powers?
Well in this chapter we see Imu transform
into a giant shadowy monster with an enormous
mouth and sharp fangs.
And he can apparently even eat fire and might
possibly have the ability to create shadow
arrows.
And to push this chapter into even higher
levels of insane hype, the Five Elders even
transform into giant creatures while they
try to prevent Sabo and the king of Alabasta
from leaving the throne room.
So with all of this crazy new information,
let’s run through some possibilities for
what these powers may actually be.
The obvious answer for Imu’s abilities is
some sort of super powerful devil fruit that
lets the user create some kind of dark monstrosities.
However, we have actually already seen the
Shadow devil fruit in the story, and this
is definitely different from those powers.
It also cannot be the darkness fruit, since
Blackbeard ate that fruit, so we are left
with a few options.
It could be some sort of legendary devil fruit
that allows Imu to either transform into or
create this enormous shadowy creature.
While I’m not totally convinced of this,
one possibility could be a mythical Moon god
fruit as a direct opposition to Luffy’s
Sun god fruit.
And there’s even Japanese mythology to support
this idea, since in Japanese the moon god
is called Tsukuyomi and is actually the cast
off husband of the sun god.
So already there are some comparisons here,
but let’s take it one step further because
in Japanese mythology, Tsukuyomi is said to
strongly believe in order and will enforce
it whenever he can, even going so far as to
kill in order to maintain order.
Hmm, sounds pretty much like the great cleansing
that was mentioned back in chapter 908.
But that is just one possibility.
Another could be that the powers are from
some other previously unknown devil fruit
ability.
But that’s just the tip of the iceberg here
because what has me super excited about Imu’s
powers is the fact that they could possess
a power that we have never seen before in
one piece.
So taking this back to devil fruits, let’s
establish a few things.
First, it has been explained that devil fruit
powers come from the actual devil inside the
fruit.
So some sort of mysterious creature or magical
energy source.
Second, we know these devils are actual things
that exist outside of the particular fruit,
because once a user dies the devil travels
and is reborn inside of another fruit.
And all of this makes me wonder if there is
an actual devil or many devils that don’t
need to exist inside of a fruit.
Like, seriously, why do they need some kind
of host in order for their powers to work.
Do you get what I’m saying here?
If not, let me lay it out simply.
What if Imu’s real power is to control or
summon actual devils that can somehow use
their own special abilities, just like devil
fruit users.
So maybe this creature we are seeing in this
chapter isn’t really imu, but is a devil
that Imu can summon at will.
It is certainly a wild idea, but one that
is possible in my opinion and could allow
Imu to use all kinds of crazy powers.
And you may be thinking, hold on Ohara, Dr.
Vegapunk told us that devil fruits represent
the desire of someone to have a certain power.
But keep in mind that this is just an in-world
theory and that doesn’t mean that these
devils can’t be the product of those original
desires.
And i mean who knows, Imu and the Gorosei
might even be the original devils or have
awakened the devil itself inside each of their
fruits.
And it would make complete sense to me that
Imu has a power that surpasses all of our
imaginations, similar to how basically no
one expected the actual powers of Luffy’s
Gear 5 transformation.
Maybe this is some way to counter devil fruits
and it has been a secret ability all along.
Whatever the true answer, there can no longer
be any doubt that Imu is a true threat and
not just someone who can only operate behind
the scenes.
And the same can be said for the Gorosei,
who have these wild beast looking transformations,
which we unfortunately don’t get to see
outside of their silhouettes.
However, their shapes do hint that they look
like ancient or mythical creatures, so I wouldn’t
be surprised at all if they each have mythical
zoan devil fruits.
But they are clearly monsters in their own
right, which makes me extremely excited for
when we return to Egghead and see Saint Saturn
join the battle.
Because this chapter basically confirmed that
the Gorosei are also not some washed up scrubs,
but they can use some insanely overpowered
abilities in a battle.
Speaking of the battle on Egghead, we could
be in for a very big surprise when we reach
the climax of this arc.
And that’s because if Saint Saturn is actually
an extremely powerful ability user, then we
could be headed for a surprising turn of events
for the straw hats.
Because remember that Law and Kid were both
soundly defeated in this very same arc.
So while we all expect Luffy to come out on
top, it is actually very possible that Luffy
could suffer a similar defeat.
We’ve discussed this in previous chapter
reviews, but Egghead has a ton of striking
parallels to the Sabaody arc.
Most importantly the crew is riding a super
high wave of confidence having just come from
Wano and defeating an Emperor of the Sea.
So knowing Oda, this could be the perfect
time to smash all of our expectations and
devil another crushing blow just like when
the straw hats were separated at the end of
Sabaody.
Because if there is one thing that Luffy ALWAYS
struggles with, it is a new, surprising power
that he can’t just punch into the ground.
Which sounds exactly like what we could be
getting from Saint Saturn whenever we return
the Egghead.
Now let’s swing all of this back to Imu
because there are actually a few more mind-blowing
reveals that were shown in the chapter.
So in the last chapter, the Gorosei actually
named Imu in front of king Cobra.
And then in this chapter, it appears that
Cobra is actually familiar with the name Imu.
And Cobra himself basically confirms that
Imu was the name of one of the original twenty
kings, but Imu furiously cuts him off before
he can say anymore.
So this seems to confirm a very common theory
that Imu is from the Void century.
And while it is possible that this Imu could
just be a descendant of the original Imu,
the information we get next makes that very
unlikely.
That’s because Imu then goes on to talk
about Nefertari Vivi as if they actually knew
the former ruler of Alabasta.
We don’t stop there because the mind-blowing
reveals just keep coming.
Next Imu claims that the D’s were “our”
enemy in the past, which I assume means the
twenty kingdoms.
Even further, he explains that basically all
of the world governments problems today, such
as pirates trying to find the poneglyphs and
scholars researching the void century, can
be traced to a single event that was all Lili’s
fault back in the Void Century.
*Pauses.
Breathes out heavily* This is literally incredible.
Finally some answers and more information
about the void century.
It’s simply amazing.
Now let’s take a moment to wrap our heads
around all of this.
Based on what Imu says, it seems there was
some plot to completely wipe out the ancient
kingdom that was almost completely successful.
However, Lili spoiled the plan somehow, maybe
by failing in a certain task or leaking some
secret information.
Why would she do this?
Well maybe because she was a D and actually
allied with the ancient kingdom.
Or maybe she was just friends with Joy Boy.
But whatever the reason, her actions allowed
for the poneglyphs to spread, which gave hope
to the future generations as we are seeing
in the current story.
And Cobra even starts to recite the secret
letter that was left by Lili, which says to
“Protect the poneglyph” and to “raise
the flag of dawn to the world.”
So clearly, Lili for some reason decided to
go against the other twenty kingdoms and leave
a trail for future generations to follow.
All of this clearly angers Imu in the chapter,
which eventually leads to Cobra sacrificing
himself so that Sabo can escape.
What’s even more incredible is that is not
all we see in this epic turn of events.
Because just as important are the people that
Imu wasn’t able to kill in the throne room.
And yes, that’s people, meaning more than
one.
Because Sabo was able to escape because of
Cobra’s sacrifice and his insanely strong
devil fruit, this guy [Wapol] was also eavesdropping
on the conversation.
When Imu finally notices Wapol, the former
ruler of Drum Island literally munches his
way through the walls of the castle and is
somehow able to escape.
Which is actually very curious to me.
Does that mean that Imu let Wapol escape?
Or maybe Imu didn’t want to make a bigger
scene than this already is?
Because clearly they have incredibly dangerous
powers and probably any one of them in that
room could have chased down Wapol.
Regardless, both Wapol and Sabo escape with
the knowledge that the world government has
been hiding more secrets than the world ever
dreamed.
And at this point, there is absolutely no
doubt in my mind that the world will soon
be learning about Imu.
Although it is odd that the world government
has not been going ballistic trying to keep
this info quite, since it has already been
a month since these events.
So maybe they don’t really care that much?
Anyway, Sabo is currently speaking with the
leaders of the revolutionary Army.
And I cannot see any reason why they would
keep this a secret.
This knowledge is just what they need to bring
more countries to their side as they try to
overthrow the world nobles.
But even if for some reason Dragon decides
to not reveal the secret, then surely Wapol
will spill the beans to this big bird [show
Big News Morgans], who is also head of the
newspapers that are delivered all around the
world.
And we’ve already seen that Morgans refuses
to let the World Government censor his news,
so unless he ends up dead then he would have
every reason to share the most mind-blowing
revelation to the entire world.
And as we just discussed with the revolutionaries,
this would surely change the world.
I mean the whole point of the empty throne
is that the rulers of the world government
collectively rule the world.
And I don’t think all of these rulers will
want any part of being ruled by a supreme
overlord.
However, none of that may matter, since the
strongest powers in the world are basically
already in play.
Those are of course the marines, the revolutionaries,
the good pirates like the straw hats, and
the not-so-good pirates like Blackbeard.
So really, what does it even matter if these
rulers throw a fit because they can’t do
much anyway, as we just saw when this kingdom
was wiped off the map [Lulusia].
What is even more insane is that with the
way things are shaping up, it is possible
all of these forces I just mentioned could
actually team up to take down Imu and the
celestial dragons.
Just think about it.
More and more, Imu is being set up as the
final villain.
And with the Holy Knights of God just introduced
two chapters ago, there is a strong possibility
that Imu and the Gorosei will be the final
villains of the story with their own super
strong force – including the Seraphim by
the way – and it will take the combined
efforts of Luffy, Blackbeard, and the fleet
admiral Akainu to keep the world from being
cleansed.
Personally this twist is super interesting
to me, because it could subvert many of the
expectations that we have had about the final
saga of One Piece.
And you know what else this final alliance
could all have in common.
D. [Make it a big and bold statement on the
screen] As we get closer to the end of the
story, this mysterious initial D that has
been around since the very start of the story
is starting to seem like the final clue that
will unveil every remaining secret.
And once again, we got even more confirmation
that the D’s were the enemies of the twenty
kings.
And in this chapter we learned that Vivi’s
family are actually part of the D tribe as
well.
So it’s not just pirates who have this initial
like Luffy, Blackbeard, and even Roger.
Nor is it just marines or revolutionaries
like Garp and Dragon.
No, this legendary tribe also included rulers
of kingdoms.
So we have to ask the questions that naturally
arise from this reveal.
Who exactly were the D?
What does it mean?
And who else is secretly a part of this family?
Before this chapter, part of me wondered if
all of the original twenty kingdoms were part
of the D’s, but that is clearly not the
case now.
Now it seems that the Nefertari family were
the only D’s of the original twenty kingdoms,
since they were the only ones to actually
stay behind when the other rulers went to
Mary Geoise.
If this is true, then they must have had some
alliance with the ancient kingdom, as we have
already discussed in the last chapter review.
Whatever the case, we could be getting the
answers to these secrets very soon because
Cobra’s last words to Sabo were for him
to tell Vivi and Luffy that his family were
all part of the D’s.
And we don’t actually know if Sabo was able
to talk to Vivi after escaping, Wapol appears
to have been listening and so he should be
able to pass Cobra’s message onto his daughter.
And since Vivi is very close to Egghead island
now, she could be meeting up with Luffy on
the scientific island very soon.
But what you may not realize is that this
would also bring Vivi to the one person who
may actually have answers to the questions
about the D clan.
Of course, that would be Robin who has already
shown interest in the D clan three times in
the past.
In chapter 180, she asked Luffy about his
family’s initial, but he had no idea what
it meant.
Then in chapter 301, this old sky knight [Gan
Fall] spoke with the straw hats about Luffy
leaving the same impression that Roger did
when he visited the sky island.
The third time, and the closest she was to
learning answers, was in Shaky’s Bar on
Sabaody, when the whole crew listened intently
as Rayleigh told them about his journey with
Roger to Laugh Tale.
And Roger’s former right vice captain basically
implied he knew what the D meant, but Robin
declined his offer to explain it all to her.
But all of this was before the time skip and
a lot has happened since then.
First she spent two years with the revolutionaries,
and in particular with Dragon, who is one
of the likeliest people in the world to know
about the D. On top of that, she has read
many of the most important poneglyphs in the
world during the recent arcs.
And while we already knew that, you may not
have ever realized that Robin actually never
shares what these poneglyphs say.
We assume they are about the void century
or about directions to Laugh Tale, but surely
at some point she will reveal the actual words
that are on the poneglyphs.
This has to happen, right?
A perfect time for this would be when the
straw hats meet up with Vivi and the Alabasta
princess asks about her newfound family initial.
But while it might seem ridiculous that Robin
has never shared this with the crew, it's
not really something Luffy cares about so
he probably never even asked her.
But it is certainly something we care about,
so I can’t wait for the questions to finally
be answered.
And even if Robin cannot answer these questions,
there are a few other characters who might
be able to.
Of course there is also Dr. Vegapunk, who
has read the entire library of research from
the island of Ohara, so he is as good a candidate
as anyone to know the truth.
Or certainly it is even possible that Saint
Saturn could reveal some answers during or
after the inevitable conflict on Egghead.
However, the true nature of the D won’t
be the only question that Vivi is asking because
she will undoubtedly want to know about her
ancient ancestor Lili, plus all of her connections
with Imu, Joy Boy, and the Void Century.
And if you want to know all about how these
three insanely important characters could
be connected, you can watch this video right
here.
Shanks for watching and I’ll see you in
the next one.